greetings everyone this is rob sanders
and today we're going to talk about how
to increase
youtube subscribers so with youtube it's
all about
subscribers the number of subscribers
you have
on youtube it's just one of the key
metrics to measure success
so gaining more subscribers can help you
achieve
more view counts on your youtube videos
so it's all about
how to get subscribers and today we're
going to talk about how to get more
subscribers
and before we begin let's just show you
what we did at simply learn
so if we look at the past 365 days on
our youtube channel you can see we
started here
back in uh if we look back at march 9
2018 we had 208
and you can see just over the course of
the year it kept creeping up creeping up
creeping up
and creeping up we've gained you know a
significant number of subscribers over
the last year
and what's our secret well it's posting
videos
so you can see we've posted a number of
videos over the course of the year
and then our subscribers have gone
basically 165 percent
over the last year so you can see it's
part of it is about posting videos
because when you post videos
you have people who can watch those
videos when you have people watch those
videos you can have engagement and then
when you have engagement you have shares
and people who like it and then other
people will see it so it's kind of a
halo effect so to speak
so getting subscribers it takes a lot
more than just posting videos and today
we're going to talk about
some tips to help you increase those
subscriptions so let's start out with
some of those tips we're going to start
with creating engagement
informative content so engaging in
informative content that's where we're
going to start
talking today about how to increase
subscriptions
then we're going to talk about
publishing videos frequently so
simply learn you can see the past 365
days
we were consistent in publishing videos
consistently throughout
the month and the weeks so another tip
we're going to talk about
is how to optimize your youtube videos
so there's a lot that goes into
optimization
but this is a key key tip to pay
attention
to because when it comes to posting
publishing videos on youtube
you need to align certain things like
keywords and content and metadata
so optimize on our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the youtube
channel so
there's some tips and tricks here you
want to do to
optimize your youtube channel producing
high quality videos we're going to talk
about
that adding a subscriber watermark to
your videos okay that's another tip
we're going to mention today
engage with our audience okay that's
what we want to do we want to engage
with our audience that's a really
key tip we're saving the best for last
promote your videos in different
platforms so
all of these tips we're going to talk
about today so let's get started
and talk about create engaging
informative content so that's the first
place we want to start okay so create
engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our channel
we have to create highly engaged and
informative content why because
not our audience is not going to pay
attention and they're not going to watch
the video and then
the engagement's not going to be high
and they're not going to share the video
and they're not going to tell their
friends or like it and so
this is where it all starts you have to
be able to plan
your content and not only planning your
content but you got to create it
so it's engaging and informative so how
do you do that well let's talk about
that so the first thing is you have to
know your audio okay so
when you create a video who you're
creating the video for
i mean that's where it all starts so
when you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world
now we know on youtube there's a lot of
cute videos about
kittens and jokes and you know people
playing games and you know everybody
likes positive things on youtube but you
know when we're talking about a specific
topic
you know we really have to hone in on a
target audience
and so if you know who your audience is
then you can really hone in on your
content okay so that's the first thing
ask yourself who
is your audience and then build your
content around that specific
audience don't build it just for the
mass general population
because it's not going to be engaging
and informative so that's the first
place to start
then you want to engage that audience
with relevant content so
if you know your audience and depending
on the topic you want to make sure
that whatever the topic is the content
matches the topic
don't veer off course if you veer off
course you're not going to engage your
viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason
the reason is the topic okay so if
they're your target audience
and they want to watch the video that's
a specific topic then the content has to
align
so plan your video script so if you know
who your audience is
and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out
so what i normally do is you know have
an outline
and then once i have the outline then i
go ahead and create
my slides if i will or my topics points
i want to talk about and then i write
out those points
i want to make sure i get all my points
in and that's what you should be doing
you want to plan it ahead of time so
that you can get all
your relevant points across that's what
makes a video informative okay you want
to ensure to give
maximum information to your audience so
the key here is maximum information
so you don't want to overload the
audience but then again you want to
cut out information so you want to make
sure that
when you're planning your script and
you're writing the outline
that you're making sure you include all
your points that you want to get across
once you include those points then go
ahead and
you know write your script and make sure
all the information for all those points
are in the script that's how you're
going to ensure you give maximum
information
but you don't want to overdo it so if
you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information
back off a little use the information to
create another video so
it's all about knowing your audience so
all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of the session
i showed you an example of simply
learned subscribers over the past 365
days
and so that's what we want to do we want
to be clear but use examples to
punctuate the content or the point we're
trying to get across
so we want to include sources from high
quality sites
so if you're going to use examples make
sure they're from
relevant high quality sites when i mean
high quality
meaning does your audience know who that
source is or that site
if it's really specific and your
audience may not know then it's probably
not high quality so just keep that in
mind
always play to your audience so you want
to start your video with an interesting
hook
so again i go back to this example if
you're still watching this
then the hook worked we showed you our
subscriptions
we showed you how we grew over the
course of a year
you could see our growth and part of it
was posting a lot of videos
with relevant and informative content
and so
you see how we did it so you're paying
attention you want to know how to do it
and so
part of what we did is exactly what i'm
telling you now we know who our audience
is
we plan out our scripts we use good
examples and we start our videos with
interesting hooks
now when we do our videos we also create
original content so that goes back to
planning your script okay you always
want to you know come across
as original and informative when you do
that you're going to be engaging
but if you're leveraging somebody else's
content then the engaging part
may not resonate because it's not your
content to begin with so
always always always use original
content okay so keep the content flow
organized
so again that goes back to an outline
you know feel free to change up the
outline
so the flow makes sense add visuals to
your content and make it appealing
always include
images to me if you can use images in
your videos
and play off the video or the images
then it's just gonna flow and make it a
little bit more engaging and appealing
meaning the content so visuals help
guide and aid in the points you're
trying to make so don't make it so text
heavy
you know accentuate it balance it with
some images
use simple language and crisp sentences
meaning
don't choose jargon don't come across
and talk above your audience
you always want to talk to your audience
and talk in a language that they're
going to understand so it goes back to
point one if you know who your audience
is
you're talking to them as if they're
right in front of you
and not you're above them or they're
below you you want to talk at them
so add cards end screens and pattern
interrupts to engage your audience and
so
youtube cards are just interactive
panels that slide in and out when a
video is playing
so it encourages interaction by the
viewer okay so you can add up to
five cards which include images text or
clickable links
so feel free to play around with some of
these features that youtube has to offer
to make your content more engaging so
tip two
publish videos frequently so creating
and uploading
videos consistently will help you
increase your youtube subscribers
so suppose you haven't published videos
for more than say a month or two months
it's likely that that audience not going
to subscribe to your channel
so think about youtube videos as a
popular tv program that comes on once a
week
when a new episode comes on based on the
regular schedule
it's consistency and that consistency is
what helps
your users stay engaged so for example
if i go back to
our youtube channel you know what helped
us gain subscribers
was our consistency in publishing videos
and the great thing about publishing
videos
is that when somebody does subscribe to
your channel they're going to get a
notification or
youtube has an option where they can get
a notification via email
so i subscribe to simplylearn's channel
i subscribe to other channels like
google analytics for example so anytime
google analytics publishes a video
i get an email that says hey google
analytics
youtube channel just published a video
and the great thing is
i'm checking my email and i'm getting
this notification in gmail so guess what
i can watch the video right then and
there just by clicking on the link
in the email i don't even have to go to
the channel but knowing that if you
publish
consistently and somebody does get the
email once a week then it's more likely
they're going to engage especially if
the content
is original engaging and informative so
frequent video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to social
media examiner
youtube channels that publish videos
more than once a week are performing
much better so
if you can afford to publish more videos
more than once a week the chances of you
gaining subscribers quicker are going to
be greater so keeping a fixed frequency
can help you quickly gain more
subscribers posting videos is like
almost like blogging i always say start
small if you could do one blog post a
month
and then once you get in a routine then
you can ramp up the frequency so
from one blog post you could do two a
month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week same with the youtube videos
you want to get into a rhythm you know
start with once a month
and ramp it up okay then you'll find
that the more you ramp it up the more
subscribers you're gonna get so tip
three
optimize your youtube videos so
optimizing your videos
will help your content rank higher on
youtube so this is a give
must it's not a given it's a must you
must optimize your videos
if you want people to see them of course
if you don't optimize people aren't
going to see them then people aren't
going to engage and then
not subscribe so it's just kind of a
snowball effect so this is an important
tip
so i mentioned it at the beginning when
we were going over
all the items we're going to discuss
this is the one item
that is a must and a given to some
degree
because if you don't optimize your
videos they're just not going to be
found so
you need that audience to watch your
video so
audiences who tend to interact more with
your content
have more chance to subscribe to your
channel but they're not going to
subscribe
if they don't even watch your video so
there is a snowball effect in play here
if we don't optimize your videos so okay
rob what are some of the tips to
optimize your youtube video well let's
go
through some of those tips so to ensure
your videos reaches
the relevant audience on youtube you
need to optimize the title description
in the video tag okay rob what do you
mean by title description and video tag
so let's take a look at that
so when you actually create your youtube
video you're going to have an
opportunity to put in a title you're
going to have an opportunity to put in a
description
and you're going to have an opportunity
to add text so those are the three
key areas okay so once you put in that
what it looks like on the front end is
this so if i go back to youtube
and here you can see another video that
we did about a month ago you could see
what is seo so if that's our topic
that's our title
uh or of the content of the video then
the title of the video is going to be
what is seo and you can see we also
added in
some other content for the title so what
is seo and how does it work
seo tutorial for beginners and then our
brand name so we have some content to
work with
for the title okay and then the
description we have a lot of characters
to work with descriptions so
use as much as you can here to describe
what the video is about
here you can see we did that and so it's
always good
to include this information okay and
then you can see we have tags up here
seo
seo tutorial for beginners digital
marketing so
we put in the necessary information here
on this video to help us rank because if
we don't
optimize it we're not going to rank and
so you can see we just put a lot of
relevant content around the description
around the title and around those tags
by doing so
we're able to optimize this video and
get found so that's just an example
three of the things you can do to help
optimize your youtube video
so if you want to watch more on how to
optimize
meta tags then i suggest maybe watching
the other
video we did on the subject how to rank
youtube videos so this goes into more
detail
about how to optimize the title the meta
description
and the meta tags but those are three
quick
fields or areas that you can use to
optimize your video so
just something to keep in mind write a
long description with keywords
timestamps and links
so what i mean by time stands for time
stamp an audience can choose the section
of the video that they want to look for
and then links prefer to include
relevant links of your other videos
so those are just some additional tips
to help keep your content engaging
so remember when your content is
engaging then people are going to like
it people are going to share it and
watch it later
so upload a captivating thumbnail okay
so you want to include a thumbnail
that's going to grab people's attention
you want to upload a transcript of the
video so
that goes back to when you're creating
your content when you write your
original content you want to
keep a transcript of the content of the
video so that you can upload that as
well
and then add a start screen and end
screen to your youtube videos
so that way you know when somebody plays
the video they're gonna see it
what it looks like up front and then we
finish it they're gonna see
an end screen at the end and so you just
don't want to keep it dark and black
and non-descriptive so according to
backlinko
using an exact keyword in your video
title can help you with rankings
so high ranking more views more views
more subscribers
so that's what i've been saying all
along you need to get these videos
optimized so again
use an exact keyword in your video title
so let's go back again to that video i
just showed you a couple minutes ago
what is seo
so here we started out with a question
what is seo that's the name of the title
that's one our exact
title of the video that's our exact
keyword okay so what is seo and how does
it work
and then seo tutorial for beginners so
what is seo
is our exact keyword and that's part of
the video that's the content of the
video that's in the title
and we use it throughout the description
as well so using that exact keyword in
your video title can help with the
ranking so whatever your topic is
your title of the video or the topic of
the video include it in the title so
backlinko also mentions that there is a
moderate correlation between a channel's
total subscribers and rankings
and so for some of you this may be
common sense
it's just like organic search if you're
not ranking you're not going to get
traffic on youtube if you're not ranking
you're not going to get eyeballs on your
videos and you're not going to get
subscribers
so higher rankings can help you to get
more subscribers but you can't get those
rankings
unless you optimize and so again just
for the sake of simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title matches
the title of the video itself when
you're publishing your description
use all the amount of content available
to you
so you can see it this entire
description has a lot of content
maximize the content and then use tags
using those three
fields those three areas can help you
optimize your video
and gain the necessary ranking you need
to get
viewers which you'll turn into
subscribers so
tip four optimize your youtube channel
so we just talked about optimizing our
videos now we're gonna turn our
attention to
our youtube channel so one of the
easiest ways to ask your views to
subscribe to your channel
is really by creating a good not even a
good a great
youtube channel trailer you also want to
add channel keywords a description
and some good artwork and then having
sections and playlists to keep your
videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good
youtube channel so let's talk about some
of these these tips here
so we want to give your audience a
preview what your channel is offering
so this is by hooking your audience with
a trailer so you can create a
trailer to you know just give your
audience an idea of who you are as a
brand
what kind of videos you're gonna be
posting and give them a kind of a taste
of what the future videos are gonna be
like okay you can
even tell them your release schedule in
the trailer so you can start out by
saying hey
hey guys we're new to this we're gonna
be posting one video a month but as we
get rolling
maybe two per month and you know one per
week
you know just being honest and open and
talking into your audience
and get them excited about future videos
that's what the trailer is all about so
you also want to keep it that the
channel description short
interesting so in your channel you want
to have a description of what the
channel is all about what kind of videos
you're going to be posting so in
addition to the trailer you want to
write something short and interesting
then we want to use
keywords in our channel descriptions
just like in the videos with what is seo
we included what is seo in the title we
included you know what is seo in the
description
and so we want to be true to what our
channel
is so pick keywords not only include
those keywords in the videos but
include them in the channel description
pay attention to the first 100 to 150
characters of your channel description
because that's what's shown next your
channel on the search results
so for example here you can see we have
a description here
simply learn is one of the world's
leading certification training providers
we partner with companies and
individuals to address
and so you can see those characters
100-150 or what shows
up in the channel description when
somebody's trying to understand
hey simply learn just uploaded this
video who is simply learning so you want
to write
short interesting channel description so
that when somebody's
first introduced to your video they
could see what your brand's all about
so and your description with an
appropriate call to action
so short interesting good call to action
at the end of the video
a good call to action would be hey check
out our next video
or check out our latest video something
that's going to gauge somebody
and get them to watch one of your videos
so you want to pick
interesting channel art so let's turn
our attention to the simply learn
channel page and here you can see we
recently
had reached a milestone so recently
reached the 200
000 k subscribers so 200 000 subscribers
is a big achievement for simply learn we
went ahead and updated our channel our
and i'm sure we will reach 500k we'll
update the artwork then too
but the point is you want to keep your
channel art kind of interesting hip and
cool
and feel free to change it out every
once in a while so you have that option
in youtube to do i mean it's
very simple so here you can see simply
learns channel
we go home get all our videos listed
here we got the about us
you know something very short
interesting about us
here's our call to action for more
information visit simply learn
so you want to make sure when you create
your channel get some good artwork in
there
put your description and play and create
your first videos
and get them posted up there and
optimize them accordingly okay so some
other tips to go with that channel art
and description is a profile picture
relevant to your brand so you always
want to
maybe put the company logo up there okay
so here you can see we have the company
logo
at accurate relevant channel keywords so
if we go back to who we are who are we
we're the world's leading certification
training provider okay that's who we are
okay we partner with
companies and individuals so we're all
about training and training
is one of our keywords so you can see at
simply learn we provide
online training and machine learning aws
amazon web services devops big data
digital marketing project management a
lot of different topics
so make sure that's included in the
channel description
feature the playlist on your home page
so if we go back to the home page
we can see here we have our channels so
you can see we have
ai machine learning trending
technologies cloud computing tutorials
devop tutorials popular videos big data
we have a lot of different
channels so you want to organize your
videos into different playlists so those
playlists are going to
feature on the home page of your channel
so how you
organize the playlist is totally up to
you but i would certainly create
a playlist for different sections so
depending on your product your services
think about how you want to organize
don't just stick all your videos
in one playlist then optimize the
playlist
titles and descriptions for search
rankings so just like the videos
themselves
just like the channel description you
have an opportunity to optimize the
playlist titles and descriptions so be
very keen on aligning the right keyword
with the playlist title
so here you can see programming language
tutorials project management tutorials
digital marketing tutorials so we're
very clear
on how we go about choosing our titles
because we want to
optimize those playlist titles okay we
can rearrange our videos
in a playlist so we want to rearrange
the videos
in a way that we're maybe putting the
freshest
the most newest the video that's been
published last
first so almost in descending order if
you will so
we want our users to see what video has
the latest
in that particular playlist so they're
seeing the most recent
first but you can rearrange your videos
any way you want
feel free to play around with it of
course you can also take the video
that's the most popular and put that up
front so people could see that first
vice versa you could take a video that
maybe hasn't gotten a lot
of views or isn't ranked particularly
high
maybe put that video up so it can get
some views and some
shares and likes so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you
just have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video
so for example if i go back to our
youtube page you can see
the top performing videos here you know
for example this one we got a nice
thumbnail here what is machine learning
so if i click on that most popular
videos
so 3 000 likes on this video a lot of
views 250
000 plus views so have a thumbnail to go
along with that particular video so
according to backlinko
youtube seo ranking factor study
discovered that
channel keywords have a small yet
significant
correlation with higher youtube search
rankings so
channel keywords so when you're
optimizing
your channel and you want to include
keywords
start with your description so if i go
back to our channel
if i go back about us make sure your
description
has those relevant keywords in it that's
where it all starts
so in case you have any doubts if you're
not sure about everything we talked
about on
optimizing the channel go ahead and drop
a comment below because
we do respond to every comment that gets
posted on our videos so if you're not
sure
how to go about optimizing your channel
when you say align keywords with the
channel what does that really mean so if
you want some clarity on that
go ahead and drop us a channel if you're
not sure about the trailer video
drop us a comment we're more than happy
to expand upon the explanation of how to
best optimize your channel
okay tip number five produce high
quality
videos so we need to
get in the habit of producing high
quality videos because
viewers don't prefer to watch videos
that have poor audio and video quality
it's just that simple you need to know
what it takes to produce high quality
videos if you don't you're just going to
discredit
you're not going to come across as
relevant you know i'm going to come
across
as qualified professional there's a lot
of things attached to poor quality
videos so
we need to create high quality videos
for the end user so let's talk about
some ways in which you can create
high quality videos and so the first is
to avoid
any noise in the background so you want
to have a nice quiet atmosphere
no distractions so people can hear you
clearly
and only you clearly you want to use
good audio recording equipment
there's plenty of options available on
the internet usually
i would recommend going with something
paid not overly expensive because you
get what you pay for so if you use
something free
it might not be of good quality and you
might not have all the features and
bells and whistles with a free option
so you know use good audio recording
equipment again it can be online
or it could be some software just make
sure that
you're able to produce good high quality
video and audio
so when you do purchase that audio
recording equipment you want
to have something similar to an input
volume meter
that way you can see whether your audio
is coming across or not
so if you're not seeing green lights
then your audio is not coming across
if it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good
quality audio you want to create your
videos in 10
80 pixel size okay that's hd and so you
want to have at least
minimum 1080. so anything less than that
it's probably going to come across
as not so good maybe staticky blurry
not professional not high def so you
want to create a high
def video and 1080 is about the
minimum you want to go and then you want
to plan your video script before
filming so it goes back to some of the
other points i made earlier
you always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
fly
then you want to use good lighting for
video recording so
you don't want to be in a dark place you
want some nice lighting
so your video comes across well lit
people could see you they're not
struggling to
strain their eyes on what it is you're
trying to show and appear because of
poor lighting
again it just comes across as
professional so if you can you know
shoot a high def video
with good audio speaking clearly having
a professional script with some good
lighting
then people are going to take you
serious and they're going to
start to listen and engage and see the
video as good
quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so
use slow motion and jump cuts wisely so
there's some features you could do with
your video
you know using slow motion and jump cuts
are some of the features
you can use to accentuate your points
and then set up a green background for
recording
again this is for you know making sure
that the video part of it comes across
in good quality
and stabilize your video recordings with
a tripod that way you're not moving your
video camera all around and
again it's coming across as shaky and
poor quality shoot horizontal videos
you don't want to go vertical it tends
to cut the screen
so you want to stay horizontal so that
people can see everything that should be
included in the video
okay you want to capture a wider shot
using a clip-on lens
again a good feature good tip to use use
that wider shot okay so you could do
that using a clip-on lens
and then choose good video editing
software i can't state this enough
because you're putting all this time and
effort into a video
you need to be able to edit it to cut
out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say
or maybe some poor quality or or you
know you just want to have a smooth
professional output for your video and
so you gotta have
good video editing software there's
plenty of options available on the
internet
again i would go with something low cost
but paid usually
free isn't exactly the way you want to
go if you're trying to create a high def
good quality video
and at the very least review your work
before publishing
i just said it a minute ago i'll say it
again you want to be able to
have a really professional video and
high def when you have a good
professional video and high def with
good audio
horizontal shots you know nice green
background image
nice well lit it's gonna come across as
professional and if you have a
professional
video then people are gonna take you
seriously they're gonna see you as a
professional
and then share or subscribe and like and
then
they're going to watch more videos and
and that's how you start to build up a
reputation
as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos
so you want to review your work because
if you don't you put all that effort
into it
and then you're gonna realize hey your
video is low quality and then you're
gonna have to do it all over again so
follow these tips get a high quality
video and you should be on your way to
ranking in fact
according to backlinko youtube
preferably
ranks hd videos so you got to have that
1080
uh pixel size that way you know your
video is gonna come across
crisp and clear and youtube prefers that
tip six
add a subscriber watermark to your
videos
so this is a great feature in youtube
so it's a feature that allows you to add
a watermark that can be shown on all
your videos
the reason why you want that watermark
because you want to keep reminding your
audience to subscribe
to your channel the watermark can be
whatever you want but
normally it's going to be some type of
logo
or brand and a call to action and so how
do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your youtube account it's it's
pretty simple
at the top right corner you're going to
select your creator studio icon
and then you're going to go to channel
select branding and then add a watermark
to your video so if we look at that
in youtube so here creator studio
on the left side navigation i'm just
going to click channel then i'm going to
click branding
and then once you click branding you
have the ability to
add your watermark and then you can add
it to the entire video at the end of the
video
and a specific start time and then just
click update and that's pretty much it
so you want to be able to add this so
that
you can brand your videos with an image
and then add that cta so this is a good
good feature for youtube
it allows you to be consistent with all
your videos
by branding and adding that call to
action tip seven
engage with your audience so you want to
be able to
interact with your audience as much as
possible just because
the video and you can't see people
doesn't mean you can't engage with them
so when you interact with your viewers
especially when you interact with them
immediately
there's gratification you know everybody
likes to be responded to
nobody likes to be ignored and so when
somebody is responded to
there's a higher chance that your
viewers are likely to going to become
customers it's just customer service is
how you really want to look at this
okay so when you engage you're creating
a service for your customers
so here are some tips on how to engage
with your audience so
first is at the end of every video
convey a thank you message to your
viewers you know thank you
for spending the time out of your busy
day to watch this video you know some of
our videos go
an hour plus long and so when somebody's
taking an hour to watch a video
it's only the least you can do is thank
them
now you could thank them and give them
some information about where to go for
more information
because if they watch the whole video
they're already engaged and they're
probably going to want to learn more
so you always want to follow up to thank
you with where to go for more
information just like
our videos always convey at the end okay
you always want to ask your audience for
their feedback or
ideas on the video so with youtube
there's a comment section and you always
want to encourage
comments so comments can be in the form
of feedback so
as you're watching this video feel free
to leave feedback
on other ways to engage with your
audience or some other tips
to increase your subscribers on youtube
so we're always looking for those ideas
we want to keep it engaging so
somebody may have some other ideas that
we didn't think about and so we always
appreciate that from our audience so we
have very much appreciate the feedback
that
our audience gives us so not all the
feedback
is always going to be positive some of
the feedback could be less than positive
or even negative
there could be mistakes so the idea
behind getting feedback is you want to
look at it you want to read it and you
want to react to it you want to react to
it positively
in the form of you know what thank you
for the feedback and
looking at the feedback weighing it and
incorporating the feedback
so you don't always want to make the
same mistake twice in a video
so if there's something definitely wrong
with the video that we're doing for
example
and somebody looked at it and gave us
feedback on it we'd certainly
definitely take a deep look into that
and try not to do the same mistake twice
because likely that user is going to
watch the video again
so you always want to learn from your
mistakes and you want to
turn those mistakes or turn those
comments into future videos okay so
create videos based on your commenter's
request
the audience is giving us feedback we
should take that
as positive and sometimes that's
creative sometimes those ideas for more
videos okay you always want to ask
questions to your audience and reward
excellent commenters so we try to ask
questions in our videos
and when users respond with the answer
if there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them in the form of
say some type of gift card or gift
certificate or promotion
or something there's always some way to
incentivize somebody
who provides excellent feedback you can
always give emoji hearts
there's so many emojis out there that
you can use emojis just to engage with
your audience based on the feedback that
they're giving the point is
if your audience has taken the time to
give feedback you always want to respond
to it and you want to respond to a
positive so emojis tend to have a
positive connotation to them
and so responding with an emoji
especially to a favorite comment
goes a long way so you can reward your
community
both on and off youtube for their
engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways
many ways not necessarily monetarily but
by recognition
you could do promotions you could do
something fun there's always ways to
reward
and prefer to host live streams and
interact with your audience so you don't
always have to do a pre-recorded video
there's certainly youtube has them other
platforms like facebook have them
instagram so you can certainly reach out
to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience
right there in the flesh so when you can
have an opportunity to talk to your
audience and engage with them
that's always going to work because they
can see personality they can see what
you're all about
and there's two-way conversation and so
that will lend to
more of a you know relationship so to
speak with your audience
so you want to create videos for
subscribers subscribers can get
impressed when a channel
dedicates a video for them so you know
take the time out
to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan base so if
you create something for them that's a
form of a reward so you can captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
youtube stories as well
you can also hear from your audience and
get their videos and use their videos
and upload them to your channel so
according to backlinko video comments
have a very strong correlation with
rankings so
as you create a video feel free to talk
to your audience and ask them
hey if you have any comments feel free
to put them in the comment section right
below this video
i see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and i'm going to ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see
about rewarding the audience or engaging
with the audience feel free to comment
we'd love to get your suggestions
because if you can engage with the
audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings
but with your subscriber base so
comments are the way to go solicit
comments
respond to the comments reward the
comments tip number eight
promote your videos on different
platforms
so promoting your videos on different
platforms has been around for many years
it's a good strategy
once you create your video on youtube
you want people to see it
you want to get it out there so if you
want to increase your youtube
subscribers this is a strategy
you have to perform so let's take a look
at all the ways you can
use and leverage different platforms to
increase your subscribers
so before you do that you want to
research discover how
and you can use different platforms so
the first thing you want to do
is look at the platforms you're already
using you're using facebook and
instagram
that's probably a good place to start
but there's other platforms you can also
leverage and we're going to talk about
those
so social media most companies most
individuals are
on in some form or fashion amongst the
most popular like
facebook and instagram so you could
start there so
with facebook you can post something
include the link
of your youtube video with facebook if
you're a business you have a business
page
you're communicating with your community
and that's a great way to get started by
promoting your youtube video you can
also do the same on twitter or
instagram or whatever platform you're on
go ahead and
post something or tweet something and
include that link to youtube
you can participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in a discussion and include
a link to the youtube video if it's
relevant and natural
so for example here there's a blog about
machine
learning you can include if you have a
video about machine learning
and the response to that conversation in
this example we've done that on reddit
okay you can list your video
in relevant and reputable directories
there's plenty of directories out there
there's plenty of video directories okay
that you can
just go ahead and publish your video on
you can use testimonial link building
okay so somebody can provide a
testimonial include the link
of your video you can opt for influencer
marketing so
if there's somebody that is associated
that likes your brand or product
and has a large following you can ask
them to post a video on your behalf it's
a great way to reach an audience
fairly quickly okay you can earn
backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example
if you look at this website here test
genix okay there's a
article here about you know certificate
of achievements
okay for aws so if you scroll down we
could see
our video is included here in this
particular web page
so this is a high quality web page okay
that's generating a backlink for us
not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic
and awareness for the video go ahead and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to
your video topic and see if you can
collaborate with them on producing a web
page to include that video you can also
take advantage of
email marketing by adding your youtube
link in the email signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like gmail or yahoo
or even hotmail or outlook is going to
have an ability
to or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature you could
simply just include
a link to the video or to your youtube
channel it doesn't have to be do a
specific video but it's a way to get
people to your youtube page or to that
video so
the whole idea is more eyeballs more
potential subscribers
engage your audience by posting your
video links on community pages
so for example you know we're promoting
something here
on a community page and that's going to
get some additional traffic
over to us you can always bookmark your
videos on bookmarking sites like
stumbledupon.com
again this is free very little time to
do this
but it's a chance for you to get the
video out there
and even generate a backlink you can
collaborate with other youtube channels
this is
always a good strategy if you're
creating a video
on a particular topic on youtube chances
are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing
it doesn't have to be necessarily a
competitor it can be a complementary
product or service and if you offer that
then go ahead and collaborate with them
and see if you can exchange your videos
on their channel and you can take their
video and put it
on your channel in a particular playlist
okay so that's a way to collaborate with
other youtube channels is swap videos
you could join high pr qa sites and post
answers to the questions related to your
video like core is always a good example
or e-hop okay so
core there's always a question being
posted
and if you have the answer to that
question in the form of your video
then go ahead and post a response with a
link to the video on youtube
it's a great way to get the video
noticed
and it's relevant and natural okay you
can embed videos in your blog post so if
you're using a platform like wordpress
for example
very easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link
in the blog post i like this option i
think blog posts are always good because
you don't have to be
text heavy with a blog post you want to
create a blog post that's nice and
balanced with an
image and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further
and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so
having a video in your blog post always
goes well in my opinion okay so you can
promote
other videos in your end screen for
example at the end of your video
you can always promote something related
like we've done here in this example
so lots of ideas get your video out
there
use them in email use them in your blog
post go to free bookmarking sites like
stumbleupon
you know collaborate with other people
on youtube you know go to core
respond to a question use social media
to your advantage there's
lots of opportunities to get your video
out there the more you can get your
video out there
the more traffic you're gonna get the
more traffic you get to the video the
more subscribers
you're going to get so that's how the
game is played in order to
get your video out there but these are
relatively you know low
time consuming ideas to get your video
some some subscribers so let's turn our
attention to some key takeaways from
today's video
tip one you always want to create
engaging and informative content
so that's where it all starts remember
think about what you want to say and do
before you do it know your audience
that's really the key takeaway know your
audience
tip two publish videos frequently okay
you don't have to start out publishing
three or four a week you know start out
publishing one a month if that's
how it works for you and then once you
build momentum once you start getting a
loyal fan base
and start getting more subscribers then
think about increasing your video output
tip three
optimize your youtube videos title
description
tags that's always a good place to start
you want to work in that keyword that's
relevant to the topic and work that
into the title work it into the
description
and work it into those tags tip four you
want to optimize your youtube channel
there's lots
of features available okay you want to
start with your description of your
channel because the description is what
shows up
when somebody does a search or sees your
video so that is key you always want to
optimize your channel as well as your
videos
tip 5 we want to produce high quality
videos
remember 1080 on the pixel you know use
good audio video equipment don't
necessarily go free
go with something low cost but make sure
you're using something that's going to
output good audio and video quality
because
people are going to take you serious tip
six good feature in
youtube under the channel settings okay
in the creator studio
you want to be able to add a subscriber
watermark that way people know who you
are
and you can add that call to action so
that they could scribe to your video
tip seven engage with your audience
comments comments comments
in fact for those watching this video
now if you have any comments on any of
the tips that we provided feel free to
put them in there
we will respond and we will reward and
that's what you want to do with your
audience you want to engage with your
audience to make them feel like they're
part
of the community and part of the
solution and then tip
eight promote your videos in different
platforms there's plenty
of opportunities from social to blog
posts to influencer marketing
to email marketing lots of different
opportunities to get that link out there
the more you can get that link out there
the more traffic you're gonna drive
the more traffic the more eyeballs are
gonna realize hey this is some good
stuff here i'm gonna subscribe to this
video i'm gonna subscribe to this
channel and i'm gonna wait for this
channel to produce more videos so these
are the tips
and with these key takeaways and these
tips you should be on your way to
increasing your subscriber base
so thank you again if you have any
comments about this video feel free to
post them
underneath we will respond and we do
appreciate it
and if you have any questions please
feel free to visit
simplylearn.com thank you and i'll see
you on future videos
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here